on Friday the labor department released
the January employment reports a
whopping 517 thousand jobs were created
and the unemployment rate edged down to
3.4 percent the lowest level since May
1969. CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger joins us to discuss the
report and what it means about the
economy until two weeks in a row very
nice fantastic very very good to see you
um this one had economists scratching
their heads more than they normally
scratch their heads why well I mean we
had a lot of data from surveys that were
showing layoffs and we've heard about
this Tech layoffs media layoffs retail
layoffs housing layoffs And yet when we
were looking at the projections we still
were expecting job creation of about 175
to 200 000 jobs but this number of more
than a half a million smash those
estimates we got positive revisions to
the previous two months we got revisions
that were higher for all of last year so
the reality is that there had been a lot
of announced layoffs maybe there is a
lag potentially between the layoffs and
the actual job losses but I feel like we
should sort of take this as a win
because it was a strong report and we do
want the labor market to be a good one
big question is how does the FED view
this data and what are they going to do
about it well I think it's interesting
for the FED because they are going to
say a half a million jobs that's a
strong labor market that might Propel
inflation further but there was a kernel
of happiness in this report for even fed
officials wage growth wage growth is
decelerating that always sounds bad for
somebody they're like wait why do I want
my agent my wages to go down and the
reason is that we want wages to grow
slowly but not too fast because when
they grow too fast they can fuel
inflation so last month wages grew
annually by 4.4 percent down from 4.8
percent the previous month down from
over five and a half percent last year
the FED is going to see this as progress
still I think the FED is almost
certainly going to raise rates again
when they meet in March by another
quarter of a percentage 29th straight
time yes now there are people that are
obviously still fearing that a recession
is coming what do you say to them you
know what it's very tough to say this
but I'm going to say it recessions are
normal they do happen we cannot actually
get rid of them so we have these
business Cycles things go up things go
down we you know and so what you need to
know is recessions are part of the
normal business cycle now are we going
to be in a recession we don't know last
year growth really did slow down we only
grew by about one percent last year the
previous year we grew by 5.7 percent the
year before that we contracted we were
shrinking by 3.4 percent so I think we
know that from all the data out there
things are slowing down the good news is
it hasn't actually meant that we have
seen a collapse of the labor market but
it is clear that we could go into a
recession this year and hopefully if we
do it's a short and shallow one and one
that doesn't have a lot of job losses so
take this win and don't panic unless you
need something unless it's emergency
right now and you need to do something
right I mean look if if I'm putting my
financial planning personal finance
great money reset hat on I'm going to
tell you to do what I always tell you to
do at a time where you're really worried
if you're in an industry that's
consolidating if you hear bad news out
of your company of course first kiss
your boss's tush because that always
helps everyone hearing that but you know
what if possible you try to scroll away
a little bit of money I would even say
that as much as I love people to put
money into retirement plans if you're
really fearful cut back on your
retirement contributions a little bit
just go up to the match if possible put
some money in cash try to keep that
stash set aside because you don't know
when the bottom could fall out so as
much as possible even if it's just 10
bucks a week it actually does help great
advice I'm gonna do it thanks Jill thank
you